tell me why
ain't nothing but a heartache tell me
why ain't nothing but a mistake i tried
to suck it up and go back to work i put
on my uniform and got in my car next
thing i knew i was
on a plane to mexico didn't even pack a
bag i bought a bundle of novelty shirts
at a nearby gift shop this one says
what's up beaches instead of [ __ ] for
human reasons but you hate humor well
i'm a joke now so
it suits me okay but how did you end up
here in mexico at the exact same tiny
resort as us jimmy's been talking about
this place for years uh referral code
gina 30. i had no idea you'd be here you
know what it's fine sir a lot of people
go on their honeymoon with their boss no
i thought if i said it out loud it would
normalize it but it's weird it's gonna
be okay how long are you staying sir
just until i get my head right but don't
worry i'll steer clear of you two you
won't even know i'm here
this place is so romantic yeah and so
intimate don't worry i'm not listening
to you i'm just thinking about how this
sea bass is cold but not as cold and
cruel as the hands of fate that have
thrust my entire life
into darkness
ah damn it i just ordered the sea bass
oh babe this is so nice there are hot
stones on our butts for no reason not on
mine my butt stones keep falling off
cause i'm so tense about halt being here
and ruining everything it hasn't been
that bad really
oops sorry
can't even float right
just push me away
everyone else does it's not great but as
long as we stay in here we're safe we're
all to santiago i'm in your room what
how patio door was open i pushed through
the hedge tell me what is it about me
that screams loser yeah you know we're
kind of in the middle of getting
massages right now sir oh how
thoughtless of me i'll get down here so
you can see my face oh no
hello the question was what is it about
me that screams
loser
oh you're back how did the breakup go i
tried to acknowledge his feelings
it wasn't easy there were a lot of them
just so confused
so sad
are you climbing out the window
no i climbed back in and we talked about
emotions for 20 minutes dear god i know
but i think it went well and at least
there was no crying well done diaz i'm
actually really glad you made me do it
this way i got to tell him that even
though it was ending
it was incredibly meaningful to me
and i'm gonna miss him oh no this is
exactly what i didn't want
you crying
i deserved that thank you for coming
diaz i want to apologize for yesterday
inserting myself into my employee's
breakup with my nephew somehow
uh backfired scenario i'm the one that
made us seem like a dumb crying baby
i'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the end of the
world to feel
things i guess not
it's up there
the thing is i really cared about marcus
but he wanted to get married and
i'm just not ready for that and if i'm
not ready with a guy as great as marcus
then
what if i'm never ready what if that was
it my one chance of love
and what if i never get a second chance
i don't know
i'm just
just sad
well i i understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying
yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this
hey there boyle how was your weekend
well actually i got a little sick oh
really i'm sorry to hear that man yeah
bullets over broadway was on tv
i came down with a big old diane weast
infection
like yeast not now i'm calling amy jake
hey ames look i'm so sorry we're not
there yet but a guy fell down the stairs
and then the old lady shot our perp and
then we stopped a bank robbery and i
lost my shoes and kayla lost her shoe
but we're almost to the hospital are you
there yet what room are you in the break
room
what why there isn't enough time i have
to have the baby here but me and my
crazy crew make it to the hospital
that's our birth story i'll screw your
bird story just get here you're giving
birth at the precinct is that safe it's
gonna be okay there's a bunch of
firefighters here right and they're
basically just glorified emts that live
together and sleep in bunk beds oh jake
she's gonna be okay i just don't think
she can talk right now okay just tell
her that i love her and i'll get there
as fast as i can hey amy can we have a
second no i'm kind of in the middle of
something you
oh yeah well
[Laughter]
yourself all right uh
okay amy i know you're in a lot of pain
but we don't have any meds here you just
got to try not to focus on it can you
distract her i got this hey me you come
out with any new binders recently i
don't want to talk about binders rosa
all right that was my big gun she's just
gonna feel this not necessarily i was
just checking to see if there's anything
we can do to help and i hate to say it
but i think there is
oh you think he's gonna get me drugs
from evidence
uh
no something way weirder is happening
hit it jeffreys
[Music]
[Applause]
you screwed up and my client's leaving
no he can't leave until i dismiss him
you've had him for 10 hours and 45
minutes 15 more and we file a harassment
claim great then i'll just keep him for
14 minutes seriously
just to be childish are you doing i told
you not to lie what were you thinking i
thought it would work
and i wanted to be the one that got him
is this about your ego are you that
desperate for everyone to know how great
you are it's not about everyone okay
it's just
i wanted you to know
oh my god
i got it
he's not answering any questions that's
okay i have no questions that's right
i'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
i'm phillip a successful periodontist
that's become addicted to diazepam a
sedative i take because i'm junkie scum
also for real addiction is a disease
that would be super empathetic if you
hadn't murdered a man what is the point
of this i'll get there so one day i'm
working late when my boss robert
surprises me he found out i was stealing
meds again jackie scum also again not
your fault there's a major genetic
component to addiction he says he's
gonna file a police report i could lose
my license we fight and something in me
just snaps so i grab the first thing i
can find and i hit him with it you still
have no murder weapon i do now
here's a pic i found on yelp of the
surgical suite six months ago and here's
a shot that our crime scene photographer
took up the same room two weeks after
the murder notice any differences we're
not answering that that's all right i
can just tell you myself the yelp shot
has six of these heavy-looking glass
awards from the brooklyn periodontics
society in the background whereas this
shot only has five what happened to
number six you murdered robert with him
you lost all control and you bludgeoned
him to death there must have been blood
everywhere but you got lucky you were in
the surgical suite it can be sterilized
you never would have gotten away with it
in your carpeted office that's not what
happened don't say anything more philly
and your office manager would have heard
all of the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play lucky again you're wrong
you put robert's body into a wheelchair
and shoved it in the elevator it's a
miracle there wasn't blood everywhere
that's not true now you're in the garage
with a corpse you panicked and left your
phone in your office and you don't have
your car keys but roberts are in his
pocket so you put him in his car and you
take off no you can't believe what
you've done no fill it you're flustered
you have no gps so you just start
driving no phillip next thing you know
you're in the pine barrens and it hits
you your uncle's cabin he has a place
there you're the luckiest son of a woman
yes it was you got lucky at every turn
no i knew exactly where i was driving i
left my phone in the office on purpose i
was in a surgical suite by design and i
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing i
made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it and melted it
back down it's already in a patient's
mouth son
oh damn
oh damn oh
damn and that is 3-0 dams
oh damn
fresh air
wow i don't say that a lot there's one
thing i still don't understand
did you know you had the wrong murder
weapon oh excellent question sir yes i
spotted the missing dental award when i
first took the case i asked around weeks
ago turns out a cleaning lady knocked it
over and shattered it then why did you
run in there like that because in
talking to you i realized what philip's
worst fear actually was that we would
think he was just some dummy that got
lucky right
he had planned the perfect crime and it
killed him when you said he was sloppy
and impulsive he needed us to know how
smart he was why
like someone else i know
yep
kevin
you